[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and we've just had a brush with death as
we've got an announcement that
deathstroke will be appearing in zack
snyder's justice league
now earlier this week thr reported that
reshoots were currently underway on
on the film and that jared leto would be
returning as the joker
joe manginello did appear with a new
haircut and this sort of teased the fans
that he could be making an appearance in
the film
now joe manginello was meant to be in
the original theatrical release
but then joss whedon stepped in and
pretty much reduced his entire role to
to that crappy post-credits scene this
was a massive shame
as i'm sure if you're like me you really
wanted to see him go head to head with
batman
but for some reason they just took him
out now collider has dropped a massive
report on this that i'm gonna link in
the description
but before we get into it make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
now that stroke did of course appear in
the post credit scene of 2017's justice
league
and this saw him be recruited by jesse
eisenberg's lex luthor
manginello recently promised to his fans
on instagram
that the upcoming snyder cut would
indeed include the original post-credits
scene
and that there would be some footage
that we hadn't seen at all appearing in
the film
now according to collider their source
explicitly told them that manganello
will be returning to shoot additional
footage i'm sorry if i'm butchering
his name by the way yeah it's very late
in england right now and i'm kind of
rushing this video but don't tell anyone
yet
now in the report collider says that a
representative for hbo max
did not confirm his return though his
source has seen a lot of evidence that
makes it seem like this is indeed
definite manchinello did appear on
twitch earlier in the week
sporting a white blonde haircut which is
also
deathstroke's look so we know they're
filming right now and you don't have to
be the world's greatest detective to put
this all together
now collider actually had the chance to
speak with manchinella recently
and according to the article when they
asked if he was going to return
he said if i was part of it that
wouldn't be my place to announce that
that would be zack's place so whether or
not that's happening
that is an answer that is below my nda
level
or whatever you want to call it so yeah
kind of giving it all the way there and
i'm absolutely i'm buzzing about this
now we do know that the snyder cut is
going to be cut up into
basically episodes and it makes sense
that they're sort of bringing back
all these actors so every single week we
get hyped for the next episode thinking
wow this big character's gonna return
whether it's the joker
deathstroke martian man hunter probably
green lantern which i'm guessing is
gonna be the next announcement
everything's really just pulling
together and i think that the show is
going to be absolutely incredible
now deathstroke is more of a niche
villain but for fans like me
i'm up absolutely over the moon to me
this is more exciting than the joker
news
as i wasn't too hot on on jared leto's
performance
but i always wanted to see what man
janello was going to do with the role
especially after after toby maguire beat
his arse in
in spider-man but don't don't tell him i
said that yeah now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on this news
who else you want to see in the episodes
and if you're as excited as we are
make sure you comment below and let us
know and if you missed our breakdown of
the joker news then definitely check it
out after this
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the win it's going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of october
and the cell will be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content like this early then you can
also join our membership program for
as little as 99 cents a month anyway
thank you for sticking with me until the
end of the video
i've been paul you've been the best i'll
see you next time take care
peace
is
you